une loi de finances pour 2013 adopté par
l'assemblée nationale dans la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances
non
c
monsieur le président je salue par
anticipation le président la commission
des finances le rapporteur général les
membres de la commission dont je sais
qu'elle finit l'instant ces travaux mais
on m'a appelé 'la tribune' comprendrez
monsieur le sénateur que je commence mon
propos mais qui n'est pas une
indélicatesse à l'égard de ses membres
je crois qu'ils comprendront mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
nous avons l'honneur avec jaune qui est
exact venir ici devant vous présenter le
projet de loi de finances pour 2013
ce que nous visons c'est une croissance
plus forte et plus équilibrée plus
solidaire je salue le rapporteur général
c'est ce à quoi le gouvernement
travaille c'est le cadre dans lequel
s'inscrit le texte que nous discutons
aujourd'hui le pellec en 2013 nous avons
une conviction c'est qu'il existe une
voie pour résorber la dette pour réduire
les inégalités pour relancer la
croissance et l'emploi et le faire d'un
même mouvement
cette voie elle est étroite les
singulières c'est celle que le président
la république est définie et c'est celle
que les français ont appelé choisi de
leurs voeux et je veux l'expliqué devant
vous aujourd'hui avant de présenter
rapidement en compagnie de jérôme
cahuzac le projet de loi de finances
nous avons une marche à franchir pendant
sept années 2013 et cette marche on est
conscient qu'elle est haute
elle est hot parce que notre économie
payent le prix de deux équipes
persistant qui n'ont pas été traitée
sérieusement depuis plusieurs années et
sur lesquels la crise actuelle joue un
rôle de révélateur
je pense bien sûr comme vous tous au
chômage avant tout qui atteint désormais
10 % la population active
je pense au creusement des inégalités
qui est fort deux extrêmes l'échelle des
revenus
les hypers et inégalités se sont
développées dans notre pays je pense à
notre déficit commercial à une
compétitivité 70 milliards d'euros c'est
un chiffre que chacun a en tête mais à
comparer aux 158 milliards d'euros
d'excédent
du côté allemand tout ça explique le
fort recul nous parle de marché à
l'exportation depuis dix ans je pense à
la désindustrialisation qui frappe de
nombreux territoires
je pense enfin à la dérive financière du
pays souligné lundi dernier par l'
agence moody's 10 700 milliards d'euros
de dette l'an dernier 86 % du pib nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 91 % du pib 600
milliards d'euros d'aidés publiques
supplémentaires en cinq ans plus de 50
milliards d'euros d'intérêts
supplémentaires à servir chaque année et
enfin tout ça dans un contexte où nous
produisons parce que ça ça c'est
fondamental mois qu'en 2007
voilà la réalité du croyez le 10 ans ça
j'ai pas l'intention de faire une
sempiternelle référence à l'héritage
mais tout simplement que nous prenions
ensemble conscience du constat objectif
de l'ampleur du redressement à accomplir
et pour faire face
pour répondre à ces déséquilibres il
faut se garder des fausses solutions
certains prônent l'austérité et pense
que pour rester compétitif pour le
redevenir plus tôt il faudrait casser le
modèle social français
ce serait irresponsable ce sera
inacceptable
ce n'est pas l'option qu'a prise le
gouvernement ce n'est pas l'option de la
majorité et d'autre al'inverse estime
que nous estimerons que nous échouons à
stimuler la croissance à ramener le
déficit à 3% du pib en 2013
c'est un débat qui est légitime et c'est
l'absence même de débat qui
m'inquiéterait mais je veux dire ici à
tous et surtout les banques
le désendettement est une nécessité
absolue que j'assume que nous assumons
l'objectif de réduction des déficits à
3%
parce qu une dette élevée conduit à
prélever lourdement sur les revenus
d'activité pour servir les intérêts
parce qu'elle favorise la rente au
détriment des revenus des travailleurs
des entrepreneurs parce qu'elles
creusent les inégalités parce qu'elle
empêche le financement des services
publics
et c'est pourquoi nous avons refusé
l'austérité en préservant les dépenses
essentielles et en finançant des
priorités mais dans le même temps je le
dis le désendettement doit être
poursuivi nous prenons nos
responsabilités
il existe nous sommes persuadés une
stratégie alternative pour allier
sérieux budgétaire et croissance justice
sociale et l'efficacité économique
stratégie qui doit se déployer au niveau
international et notamment européen et
national mais en même temps c'est le
même agenda de croissance pour le pays
une cohérence qui en plus est construite
sur le long terme et pas seulement sur
un an
je veux d'abord vous présenter sa
stratégie avant de venir
in fine et rapidement au projet doit
finances que jérôme cahuzac dans sa
responsabilité de mise du budget vous
présentera de manière plus précise
évidemment sur la stratégie
je veux insister sur le fait qu elle
actionne plusieurs leviers
internationaux européens nationaux avec
un but et un seul renouer avec une
croissance plus forte et plus solidaire
à l'international notre démarche est
claire c'est le refus de l'austérité
c'est la lutte contre les dérèglements
de la finance c'est la relance de
l'activité mondiale airs plein nous
ouvrons redémarrage la croissance
mondiale et singulièrement européenne
pour tirer en quelque sorte notre propre
reprises et je veux vous dire que sous
l'impulsion de la france pas seul
évidemment mais elle joue son rôle tout
ce rôle une véritable réorientation de
la construction européenne a été engagée
et que les conditions d'une sortie
durable de la crise de la zone euro me
semble en passe d'être réunies je le dis
avec prudence mais avec détermination au
lendemain d'un réunion de l'eurogroupe
où j'ai passé la nuit
n'avons pas tout à fait réussi à trouver
une solution pour la grèce mais nous
allons le faire nous devons le faire
nous pouvons le faire nous le ferons dès
lundi parce qu'il est fondamental que ce
pays qui a fait tant d'efforts trouve du
côté de ses partenaires européens
la solidarité et dans en même temps le
bon respect des finances publiques de
nos états c'est ce à quoi nous oeuvrons
la réorientation a été lancé au conseil
européen des 18 et 19 juin
elle se concrétise par l'arc application
de la banque européenne d'investissement
par des projets susceptibles d'entrer
dans le champ de ce qu'on appelle les
project bande par les conditions d'une
coopération renforcée en vue d'une taxe
sur les transactions financières tant
attendu temps différé est aujourd'hui
présente et je crois en effet que nous
sommes en train de sortir de la zone
rouge entrant quelques indicateurs
d'abord la création du mécanisme
européen de stabilité qui a été lancée
le 8 octobre qui dispose d'une force de
frappe d'un pare feu comme ils disent on
dans notre jargon de 500 millions
d'euros ensuite le 500 milliards d'euros
suite à supervision bancaire qui avance
mme devrions être en mesure de présenter
un texte européen d'ici la fin de
l'année puis la création pas la banque
centrale européenne d'un nouvel
instrument d'intervention rendue
possible par la dynamique qui s'est
enclenchée en europe
oui cette politique européenne sur tous
les dossiers européens l avance et sur
tous ces dossiers sur tous ces sujets
nous sommes-nous france non seulement
moteur mais écoutez nous assumons
j'assume je crois en l'europe de
participer aux jeux communautaires parce
que c'est dans l'intérêt à long terme de
notre pays et en france en france nous
voulons répondre à l'urgence économique
et social tout en préparant activement
le retour de la croissance
la croissance viendra de notre activité
internationale et elle viendra aussi
bien sûr d'impro politiques économiques
nationales que nous déployons en trois
étapes la première étape c'est la
réponse à l'urgence économique et social
c'est le sens du train de mesures que
nous avons décidé au cours de l'été qui
visait à soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
la consommation restant un moteur
historique pour la croissance française
la deuxième étape
l ailier c'est celle qui nous occupe
dans ce projet de votre finances c'est
le moment du
redressement j'y reviens dans quelques
instants mais il était capital de lancer
dans le même temps une troisième étape
celle des chantiers trop fonds
structurels pour poser les fondements
d'une croissance de long terme qui soit
plus forte est moins inégalitaire et
cette étape
elle prévoit notamment une réforme du
financement l'économie à laquelle je le
dis ici car je reviendrai nombre devant
vous à plusieurs reprises pour évoquer
ces sujets je crois beaucoup
j'ai présenté mi octobre en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi portant
création de la banque publique
d'investissement cette banque et ce
projet doit être en discussion devant
l'assemblée nationale était hier
plusieurs reprises devant la commission
des finances s'est tu manques
elle sera opérationnelle en janvier 2013
ce sera la banque des très petites
entreprises ce sera la banque des pme
ce sera la banque des pme industrielles
sucera la banque des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire elle va financer
leurs projets de développement leur
croissance à l'international leurs
investissements dans l'innovation leurs
efforts à l'exportation et au delà de
cette création nous avancerons pour
réformer les pas réglementé s'est
entamée pour réformer le secteur
bancaire un projet de loi sera présenté
au conseil des ministres le 19 décembre
afin que l'épargné des français qui
demeure abondante soit mieux allouer
vers l'investissement vers le long terme
vers l'économie réelle
en vérité et puis il ya bien sûr cet
immense chantier de la reconquête de
notre compétitivité qui s'est ouvert
avec le pacte présenté il ya deux
semaines par le premier jean marc
ayrault autour d'un crédit d'impôt
simple efficace que je crois bien pensé
il permettra aux entreprises de dégager
des marges de manoeuvre pour financer
l'investissement et l'emploi
il représentera un allègement net de 20
milliards d'euros de la masse salariale
entreprises à terme nous avons calculé
qu'il pourrait qu'il pourrait créer
trois cent mille emplois et augmenter le
pib de 0,5 point sur le quinquennat il
aura un impact positif pour les
entreprises supérieure d'un tiers
je veux le dire ici parce que
représentait une baisse des cotisations
sociales
ce sera un signal économique perceptible
dès 2013 c'est pour ça que je n'évoque
maintenant avec un coût pour les
finances publiques qui lui sera dit
à 2014 impact équilibré car si nous
tendons et je le dis la main aux
entreprises au travers du crédit d'impôt
nous demandons en même temps clairement
et fermement des engagements en échange
en matière de gouvernance en matière de
rémunération en matière de civisme
fiscal
nous espérons aussi que nous pourrons
avancer ensemble dans la grande
négociation sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi dit lancées par lula demandé
consultation faut pas organiser en ce
moment même par le premier ministre et
ses négociations je crois qu'elles sont
fondamentales pour l'histoire des
relations sociales mais aussi pour
l'économie française
voilà en quelques mots les les grands
chantiers en faveur de la croissance
nous avons amorcé qui vont mobiliser
l'ensemble dû gouvernement et notamment
nous les ministres qui travaillent
mystère du comité des finances en cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois et nous entendons et tenir toute
notre place bien sûr la stratégie de
finances publiques c'est pour ça que
j'ai évoqué en préambule tout cela elle
s'inscrit dans cet agenda de croissance
parce qu'il exprime parfaitement cette
démarche
d'abord et c'est un progrès qui nous
semble décisif nous étions là ici devant
vous avec jérôme cahuzac à plusieurs
reprises pour l'évoquer nous avons un
pilotage intelligent des finances
publiques puisque nos objectifs sont
désormais explicite et en termes de
solde structurel et par ailleurs nous
avons mis en place avec correction qui
respecte la représentativité et la
souveraineté la représentation nationale
dans ce cadre rénové notre action sera
conduite en deux temps un premier temps
celui du redressement de la remise en
ordre des finances publiques avec un
désign financiers que nous vous regardez
en face qui est massif nous devions le
corriger nous devons nous quand j'ai
nous avons choisi de faire porter
l'essentiel de l'effort en ce début de
mandat et notamment dans cette année
2013 est une année clé coeur compliqué
mais décisive avec à ce moment là dès
l'inversion de la courbe de la dette des
mesures de redressement déjà été voté et
c'est le redressement qui est aussi un
des signes que veut donner ce projet de
loi de finances pour 2013 et le deuxième
temps ce sera celui du retour
l'équilibré structurel des comptes
publics déficit public sera ramené sous
les 0 5 point du pit dès 2015 puis à l'
équilibre structurel en 2016 et 2017
ça veut dire qu'une fois passé ce cap
compliqué 2013 encore 2014 bourdonnement
plus de marge de manoeuvre à l'action
publique
je voudrais insister ici sur un élément
qui est trop peu pris en compte c'est
que le sérieux budgétaire n'est pas un
boulet ce n'est pas une contrainte
ce n'est pas un obstacle il n'est pas
synonyme d'austérité
il n'est pas incompatible avec une
volonté forte de changement avec un
engagement progressisme pour ce qui nous
concerne de gauche avec une démarche de
justice devrait distribution il doit
être compris au contraire comme une
condition de la compétitivité et
d'égalité en même temps pour notre
économie dans son ensemble
ainsi lorsque les conditions de
financement des états espagnol et
italien
je salue au passage le président luc
italienne qui est en visite d'état de
notre pays qui est un grand européen et
nous sommes solidaires de nos voisins
lorsque les conditions de financement de
ces états se sont dégradées c'est
l'ensemble de leurs économies qui a
souffert les entreprises ne peuvent pas
emprunter à des taux inférieurs à ceux
de leurs états et la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons désendetter le
pays et réduire nos déficits c'est pour
préserver notre capacité d'emprunt à
taux faibles qui sert en réalité à
l'ensemble de l'économie
et c'est pour cette raison-là nouveau
poursuivre la consolidation de leurs
finances publiques
le désendettement en même temps s'il est
un impératif doit être intelligent nous
exigeons que nos efforts soient jugés
sur la base des résultats obtenus et non
sur les moyens mis en oeuvre le
gouvernement et la représentation
nationale sont maîtres du comment c'est
à dire de la maîtrise des choix
financiers des choix politiques qui
permettent le redressement ce
désendettement il aussi s'inspirer des
expériences réussies qui ont défait
d'ailleurs j'observe que les parcours de
désendettement qui ont fonctionné qui
ont rassemblé aussi des pays sont ceux
qui combinent un effort fiscal une
réforme des administrations
un examen minutieux des dépenses
publiques une réflexion sur
l'articulation des pouvoirs centraux et
territoriaux un souci de pédagogie et de
lisibilité l'action menée et enfin une
implication renforcée qui est au coeur
de tout le reste du parlement dans les
règles
'l'annonce financière des réformes de
compétitivité du pays ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya non seulement de notre part un
effort budgétaire mais qu'il ya un grand
chantier de modernisation de l'action
publique qui doit s'engager dans ce pays
pauvre et man transformer les choses
enfin ce désendettement poids
d'intelligent il leur poser sur un
effort partagées mais différenciées pour
ne pas nuire à la croissance
partager partager entre secteur public
et secteur privé au sein des
administrations publiques pour ne pas
avoir d' angles morts dans l'effort de
redressement mais aussi différencier
pour les chercher les marges de
manoeuvre là où ils existent sans peser
uniformément sur les moteurs de la
croissance et au sein des
administrations publiques en particulier
pour ne pas reproduire un systématisme
aveugle destructeur qui a plu à certains
égards représenter la rgpp
on nous reproche ici ou là de ne pas
baisser suffisamment les dépenses
moi je réponds que l'effort de maîtrise
de la dépense de réduction des dépenses
que nous menons il est lourd il est
important il est réparti entre les
administrations il sera constant sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat et par
ailleurs nous ne pouvons pas ne devons
pas aller plus loin parce que la dépense
publique est aussi un facteur de soutien
d'activités tout est affaire d'équilibré
en la matière n'oublions pas que les
baisses de dépenses hôte aussi un impact
récessif plus récessif que les hausses
de prélèvements donc faisons en sorte de
garder si les capacités pour faire jouer
les stabilisateurs automatiques voilà
présenté un peu longuement mais c'est
aussi le rôle du milieu comme les
finances que d'éclairer les perspectives
ou delà même du projet de loi de
finances nous examinions aujourd'hui la
cohérence de notre stratégie économique
le projet de loi finances pour 2013 qui
est soumis à votre examen s'inscrit
évidemment en totale cohérence il est la
première pierre fondatrice avec cette
ligne que je viens de vous présenter je
vais laisser sur le visage ils ont
exposé plus que le détail ces éléments
la philosophie le sens ton quelques
minutes avec la précision et le talent
qui sont les siens mais je veux pour
terminer montrer comment le plf
s'inscrit dans la vision d'ensemble que
je viens de décider
oui ce plf s'inscrit
notre stratégie économique c'est un
budget d'assainissement des comptes mais
c'est un budget d'assainissement juste
vous connaissez l'ambition de ce plf qui
amorce l'assainissement des conclu que
j'évoquais quelques instants un déficit
public ramené à 3% du pib en 2013 mais
la vérité c'est que si le redressement
est un impératif il existe aussi un bon
et un mauvais redressement ou deux bons
et de mauvais redressement le mauvais
redressement c'est celui qui assèche les
administrations celui qui frappe le plus
modeste de plein fouet mais qui
épargnent ceux qui sont en position de
contribuer davantage à l'effort
c'est celui qui paralyse des entreprises
le bon redressement
c'est celui que nous vous présentons
celui qui est juste celui qui est
limitée dans le temps
si celui qui ouvre la voie à une reprise
de la croissance de demain c'est celui
qui préserve autant que faire se peut
dans un contexte d'efforts la demande
c'est celui qui ne nuit pas à notre
offre productive mais qui crée au
contraire les conditions du rebond et le
gouvernement assume pleinement
l'exigence de ce budget parce que les
fortes qu'il propose est et j insiste un
effort juste c'est un effort juste parce
qu'il est partagé entre les
administrations publiques les ménages
les entreprises mais aussi parce qu'il
est différenciée jeudi au sein de
chacune de ces catégories c'est un
effort juste parce qu'il rétablir la
progressivité de l'impôt et nous
l'assumons et en particulier de
l'imposition des personnes progressivité
qui a été mise à mal lors des
quinquennats précédent l'effort de 2013
ne repose pas sur des mesures de hausse
générale et indifférenciée des impôts je
ne veux pas laisser dire ça ça a été
trop dit mais surtout de la forme
profonde de la structure des
prélèvements
c'est le sens de la création d'une
nouvelle tranche à 45% au delà de cinq
cent cinquante mille euros c'est le sens
la limitation de la leaf en tâches qui
pourraient être retirés des niches
fiscales
c'est le sens de l'imposition que nous
avons maintenu du capital sur la
position du travail même si vous le
savez réseau national nous devons
consentir certaine évolution qui tu
crois pouvait être justifiée par des
analyses économiques que nous avons
prises en compte il n'est pas normal que
l'on soit moins taxés lorsqu'on
s'enrichir en dormant que lorsqu'on
peine en travaillant les détenteurs des
plus hauts revenus et patrimoines sont
appelé à un effort de solidarité
exemplaire et pour partie exceptionnelle
la contribution exceptionnelle
solidarité
et la réforme de l'isf les concernent
également directement permettent de
demander plus à ceux qui peuvent le plus
je n'oublie pas que cette contribution
exceptionnelle vont l'évoqué sera neutre
pour 99 9 % des contribuables
la fin d'heuliez 7 portant sur les 5 %
des ménages aux revenus les plus élevés
je veux atteindre ici de mauvaise
polémique
notre réforme de l'impôt sur le revenu
elle est clairement ciblé les mesures
sont ciblés et on sait en effet ceux qui
permettront ce qui permettra d'éclairer
ici vos choix
ce débat ce budget préserve enfin et
j'en termine par la nos capacités de
croissance
il n'y a pas et je le redis ici avec
force
il n'y a pas d'efforts acceptable sans
perspectives meilleures qui permettent
de le justifier
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a élaboré
un budget qui préserve le capacité de
croissance du pays tout en opérant un
effort il le fait parce qu'ils épargnent
largement les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont le fer de lance
notre économie il le fait parce qu'il
permet aussi d'étendre le crédit d'impôt
recherche par ailleurs sanctuaire ids et
aux dépenses d'innovation des petites et
moyennes entreprises
il sera complété en loi de finances
rectificative par des mesures de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale c'est un budget
qui réduit de 30%
l'écart de taux implicite d'imposition
entre pme et grandes entreprises pour
rééquilibrer l'imposition c'est un
budget qui sollicitent l'état pour le
redressement mais qui s'efforce aussi de
préserver les dépenses d'investissement
voilà ce que ce budget je m'en tiens là
je voudrais finir rappelons les enjeux
de ce texte
nous sommes en train de refondre
entièrement le paysage nos finances
publiques
la forme vous en avait déjà parlé le
contenu aussi nous avons élaboré nous
avons défendu devant vous si textes
financiers structure en six mois
la loi de finances rectificative de
juillet le plf pour 2013 c'est celui que
nous vous présentons le plfss pour 2013
le projet de loi de programmation
pluriannuelle
le projet de loi organique relative à la
gouvernance et à la gestion et la
programmation des finances publiques le
plfr de novembre projet de loi de
finances pour 2013 que vous examinez
c'est au fond le premier jalon du
désendettement compétitif et juste de
nous poursuivons je sais qu'il suscite
de nombreux débats et c'est normal je ne
veux pas les balayer d'un revers de main
au contraire nous sommes la peau des bas
mais le redressement du pays
c'est une mission propre exigeant trop
importantes pour pouvoir être
l'accomplissement des seuls gouvernants
c'est nécessairement par la mobilisation
de toutes les forces économiques
celle qu'on appelle les forces vives du
pays de la société civile et de vous
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
que nous réussirons il nous faut je pèse
mes mots
être à la hauteur de responsabilité
historique la france n'a pas traversé
une crise de l'ampleur de celle que nous
vivons depuis 50 ans et le redressement
c'est un enjeu tel que nous savons que
maintenant nous sommes un peu à la
croisée des chemins
nous le réussissons et nous serons
toujours cette cinquième économie du
monde une économie forte diversifiée dès
lors qu'elle redresse sa compétitivité
exportatrices créatrice respectés et si
nous ne l'entrepôt non pas ici des
réformes ne sont pas conduites et mener
à bien
alors nous pouvons tomber dans une
spirale qui est la spirale du
déclassement qui ne veut pas parler ici
de déclin parce que la france est forte
mais de la perte d'influencé
et c'est bien ça qui était en jeu cette
responsabilité-là faire le bon choix
entre ces deux alternatives entre ces
deux alternatives c'est c'est la nôtre
aujourd'hui la nôtre c'est celle du
gouvernement
bien sûr c'est celle de la
représentation nationale nous n'avons
pas le droit de nous des fausses et
parce que d'autres l'ont fait avant nous
parce que nous en payons le prix
aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui c'est bien l'heure des
choix politiques courageux ambitieux
fondateur fondamentaux pas le fuite en
avant pas êtes un moment pas la
détermination
je crois que et nous le vivons ainsi
avec jérôme cahuzac
le gouvernement a la conscience de ses
responsabilités
nous voulons nous montrer à la hauteur
nous ne ménageons pas notre peine nous
écoutons beaucoup et nous cherchons la
voix qui est la plus juste la plus
efficace est celle qui permet de
préserver les capacités de la france ne
souhaite que nous soyons aider dans
cette tâche importante historique
je le répète par les représentants de
sept chambres le projet de loi finances
pour 2013 projet de loi de finances
certes difficile nous sommes conscients
mais qui a été élaboré avec beaucoup de
soin avec que cette vision stratégique
nous en offre je crois mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur et c'est dans cet
esprit que nous entrons dans ce débat
l'occasion je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre est dans la
suite que la discussion générale la
parole et à monsieur jérôme cahuzac
ministre chargé du budget merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président la commission des
finances sur la portière général
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs pierre
moscovici vient de l'indiquer ce projet
de loi de finances initiale que le sénat
s'apprête à examiner et tu as à la fois
une suite et un précédent c'est la suite
de la loi de finances pluriannuelle que
votre haute assemblée a déjà gagné c'est
la suite du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale qui est aussi la
suite de leurs finances rectificative
présenté au parlement et donc devant
vous cet été dernier et c'est aussi un
précédent car nous le savons
une deuxième voie qui dansent
rectificative bien classique
interviendra lors du mois de décembre
juste avant la fin de l'année cette loi
de finances est donc un ensemble dont
toutes les parties se tiennent et se
complètent cet ensemble est grave
le nier serait absurde cet ensemble est
grave mais le gouvernement
le tient pour nécessaire tant il lui
paraît indispensable de rompre avec une
équation budgétaire dont on connaît des
termes des termes qui ont été maintenus
ces dix dernières années des termes qui
rendent en vérité cette équation
insoluble
quelles sont ses termes il s'agit dans
un premier temps de diminuer les
ressources sans diminuer loin s'en faut
et à due concurrence les dépenses
les exemples abondent
ces dix dernières années entre 2002 et
le rendement de l'impôt sur le revenu a
été délibérément baisser d'environ 30%
c'était d'ailleurs un engagement de la
campagne électorale présidentielle
victorieuse de jacques chirac et de fait
les différents ministres du budget
notamment jean françois copé ont mis un
soin particulier à diminuer le rendement
de cet impôt sur le revenu de 30 % il
sans faute
aujourd'hui de 17 milliards d'euros de
recettes qui manquent
objectivement il s'est agi aussi dans
cette même période de majorer la dépense
fiscale puisque les niches fiscales ont
progressé en nombre elles se sont
surtout aggravé en coût pour l'état ce
coût des niches fiscales était de 50
milliards d'euros en 2002 75 milliards
d'euros en 2007 une augmentation
considérable de 25% sans que je le
répète dans cette période la dépense
publique n'ait été baissé à due
concurrence et le même mécanisme les
mêmes termes cette équation insoluble
ont été maintenus entre 2007 et 2012
je voudrais rappeler que à l'été 2007 le
paquet fiscal fut adoptée par la
majorité ump pour un coût de 10 à 12
milliards d'euros intégralement financée
par l'emprunt que la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle qui était peut-être
nécessaire mais dont le coût ne fut
assumer là encore que par l'endettement
un coût de 7 à 8 milliards la première
année un coût de 5 milliards d'euros en
vitesse de croisière le même exemple
peut être donné avec l'abaissement de la
tva dans la restauration encore une fois
je ne préjuge pas de la légitimité de
cette mesure ni même de son intérêt pour
les entreprises concernées je me permets
simplement le constater que son coût
réel est net de 1,3 milliard d'euros
le fus a su mais là encore que par
l'emprunt comment imaginer résoudre
cette équation qui voit les ressources
de l'état délibérément abaisser ses
dépenses délibérément augmenté comment
imaginer que cette équation ait pu se
résoudre autrement que par l'endettement
mais c'est bien cet endettement
insupportable qui aujourd'hui contraints
l'action publique des autorités de la
france est bien cet endettement
tiens abouti à un avis
ce temps de la position de la france
peut-être pas dans le monde mais
certainement en europe est en tout cas
au sein de la zone euro c'est cet
endettement qui dès la loi de finances
rectificative a obligé le gouvernement à
prendre des mesures difficiles donc il
est finalement peu surprenant que
l'opposition les condamne comme il est
peu surprenant que la majorité et les
membres du gouvernement rappelle aux
membres de cette opposition
ce qu'est l'origine exacte précise et
véridique des efforts qu'il nous faut
désormais demander aux français car
l'endettement entre 2002 et 2007 a
progressé de 300 milliards d'euros la
crise n'était pas là car l'endettement a
progressé entre 2007 et 2012 de 600
milliards d'euros certes la crise était
là mais l'on sait ce que la cour des
comptes a dû porter comme jugement
notamment concernant l'année 2010
indiquant que le déficit public cette
année là était dû pour un tiers à la
crise et pour les deux tiers aux
politiques publiques menées
souverainement par les autorités de
notre pays
le gouvernement veut rompre avec les
termes de cette équation impossible
l'endettement n'est plus l'issue
inéluctable aux décisions politiques
prises par le gouvernement français sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et du
président de la république et je
donnerai dans la présentation du budget
les éléments me semble-t-il probant de
la rupture que ce gouvernement souhaite
opérer avec la période des dix dernières
années une rupture nécessaire car cette
équation insoluble ne débouchant que sur
l'endettement présente des inconvénients
dont chacun connaît la réalité c'est
d'abord l'inefficacité qui est au rendez
vous au delà des 900 milliards d'euros
de dette
je veux dire au delà d'un chiffre tout à
fait impressionnant nous savons tous que
quand la puissance publique lève sur le
marché des capitaux des sommes aussi
considérable c'est autant de capitaux
qui ne peuvent s'investir dans le
secteur productif
c'est autant en moins pour la
compétitivité c'est autant en moins en
réalité et à terme pour la production de
richesses et de valeur c'est à dire
autant au moins pour favoriser l'emploi
inefficace incontestablement comme en
témoigne le déficit du commerce
extérieur conséquence directe du
mécanisme financier que je viens
d'indiquer
et plus de 70 milliards d'euros de
déficit budgétaire
l'année dernière c'est également au delà
de l'inefficacité un mécanisme
terriblement dangereux auquel nous avons
assisté pierre moscovici l'a indiqué
nous en était à ce point dépendre à ce
point des marchés le cas échéant des
agences de notation c'est abandonner
qu'on le veuille ou non une part de
notre souveraineté nationale à des
institutions ou à des individus qui
n'ont elles et eux aucun compte à rendre
au peuple lors même que vous même le
gouvernement
l'ensemble des élus de ce pays ont
d'abord le devoir de rendre des comptes
à ceux qui nous donnent mandat de
diriger ce pays
c'est aussi dangereux à l'égard des
générations futures puissent que
moralement il ne me semble pas que nous
avons réellement le droit de leur faire
supporter le remboursement de dette
correspondant à des dépenses dont en
vérité elle ne profite nullement
puisqu'il s'agit pour beaucoup le
dépenses de fonctionnement compétitivité
place de la france en europe
aléa moral à l'égard des générations
futures il faut rompre avec cette
politique de l'endettement c'est à dire
avec cette politique consistant à
diminuer les ressources tout en
augmentant les dépenses et en comptant
sur les marchés pour pouvoir au
financement qui manquent
mécaniquement et oserais-je dire
inéluctablement ce projet de budget
s'inscrit donc dans cet ensemble dont
j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il est et
graves dont j'ai déjà précisé que le
gouvernement le tenez pour nécessaire un
effort est donc demandé au pays un
effort dont nous voulons croire non nous
faisons tout pour qu'il soit juste et
soit perçu comme tel car nous avons la
conviction que si nos concitoyens sont
bien persuadés que cet effort est
nécessaire nous savons qu ils ne
l'accepteront qu'à la condition qu'il
soit perçue comme juste et nous nous
efforçons de le rendre le plus juste
possible pierre moscovici a précisément
indiqué sur qui portait sinon
l'intégralité de l'effort à l'occasion
de l'examen de l'ensemble de ces textes
en tout cas l'essentiel la très grande
majorité de cet effort oui c'est à
ceux-là ménages et entreprises dont nous
estimant que les uns et les autres
peuvent consentir les efforts que nous
demandons c'est à cela
que nous demandons un effort particulier
un effort rude qu'il ne s'agit pas de
nier qu'il s'agit d'assumer
car après tout c'est l'intérêt supérieur
du pays qu'il s'agit bien de préserver
cet effort est rude cet effort est
indispensable il n'empêche pas pour
autant le gouvernement de mettre en
oeuvre des politiques nouvelles mais des
politiques qui elles ne sont pas
financées par l'emprunt mais qui le sont
par des ressources que nous assumons ce
fut le cas de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire majoré de 25 % chacun sait
comment cette allocation dans les
scolaires et financé les par un déport à
partir de l'envelope du quotient
familial une enveloppe de 13 à 14
milliards d'euros dont nous disent
trayons 480 millions d'euros afin de
majorer l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
pour les foyers les plus modestes ceux
là même qui d'ailleurs ne bénéficie pas
du quotient familial puisque ces foyers
là ne sont pas précisément éligibles à
l'impôt sur le revenu politique nouvelle
aussi que de permettre à celles et ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler très tôt
dans leur vie professionnelle en général
pour effectuer des métiers très pénible
dangereux des métiers à faibles
perspectives de carrière ou d'évolution
de rémunération pour vaincre à cela de
prendre leur retraite une fois les
trimestres cotisés et quel que soit
l'âge auquel ils décident de la prendre
l'espèce 60 ans cette mesure-là a été
financée par un relèvement de cotisation
à la fois sur les salariés sur les
entreprises de 0,1 point dans chaque cas
oui c'est un prélèvement supplémentaire
mais c'est un prélèvement qui est au
service de la justice et c'est une
mesure que nous assumons parfaitement
politique nouvelle aussi qui consiste à
restaurer ce grand service public qu'est
l'éducation nationale en mettant un
terme aux suppressions aveugle
systématique de postes intervenues ces
cinq dernières années nous avons
commencé à restaurer ses moyens humains
nous continuons à restaurer les moyens
humains de la même manière que nous
mettons un terme aux suppressions de
postes dans l'effort de sécurité de
police et de gendarmerie ou dans les
effectifs de la justice n'ont pas que
tous les effectifs du ministère de
l'intérieur soit préservée dans le
projet de budget nous supprimons 614
équivalents temps plein dans ce
ministère
nous créions 480 postes dans les forces
de sécurité nous persévérons année après
année pour aboutir à satisfaire la
promesse du candidat françois hollande
etc avait indiqué que 5000 postes
supplémentaires seraient créés au sein
des forces de sécurité police et
gendarmerie oui nous continuerons par
exemple au ministère de l'économie et
des finances année prochaine 2353 postes
seront supprimés mais plus de dix milles
entre 2012 et 2013 que 2010 1011 pour
être précis seront créés au sein de
l'éducation nationale car c'est une des
priorités du gouvernement et si je me
permets en vous citant ces chiffres mais
là messieurs les sénateurs de vous
indiquer où des postes sont créés ou
sont supprimés c'est parce que au total
et sur la mandature
les effectifs de l'état resteront sable
et c'est parce que au total et en fin
d'année dernière de l'année prochaine en
fin 2013
il y aura net 2317 de postes supprimés
au sein de l'appareil d'état non pas que
j'ai la religion de la suppression des
postes au sein de l'éducation sein de
l'éducation nationale ça va sans dire
mais au sein de l'état mais parce que
les postes créés cette année doivent
être compensés année après année par des
suppressions qui excèderont en nombre
les créations dans les ministères ou
l'émission privilégiée nous respecterons
l'engagement de la stabilité des
effectifs car nous respecterons
l'engagement d'une évolution de dépenses
de zéro valeur sur le champ des dépenses
de l'état c'est à dire et d'ailleurs
cette règle fut instaurée par le
gouvernement précédent
nous la maintenons zéro valeur hors
service de la dette et service des
pensions 0% zéro valeur en 2013 par
rapport à 2012 puis je me permettre de
rappeler qu'en 2008 c'est à dire pour la
première année de la précédente
mandature
là où le gouvernement par une économie
très maîtrisée de la dépense s'efforce
de respecter ce zéro valeur et y
parviendra le gouvernement précédent lui
augmenter la dépense sur ce champ puis
je me permette de me faire remarquer que
tout compris là où le budget de l'état
augmenté de 0 3%
le précédent gouvernement fillon en 2008
augmenter les dépenses de l'état de 3,3
pour cent
à dire dix fois plus que ce que nous
nous apprêtons à faire ici je me permets
de citer ce chiffre avec un rapport de 1
à 10 dans l'évolution de la dépense
entre ce que le gouvernement de jean
marc ayrault s'apprête à faire en
première année pleine de mandature est
ce que le premier gouvernement fillon a
fait en première année de mandature
c'est peut-être pour relativiser des
critiques que je croise inévitable mais
infondée et qui voudrait que ce
gouvernement ne maîtrise pas la dépense
quand les précédents l'avait fait il me
semble qu'un rapport de 1 à 10 fait
litière de cet argument et je n'aurai de
cesse de rappeler ces chiffres dès lors
que d'autres n'auraient de cesse
dénoncer ce que je crois être des
contrevérités patente
donc nous maîtrisons la dépense nous
maîtriserons cette dépense est nette des
politiques nouvelles que nous mettons en
oeuvre il y à bien une économie de 10
milliards d'euros sur l'évolution
tendancielle de la dépense publique là
des prochaines une économie qui se
déclinent et qui d'ailleurs figure bien
dans les documents budgétaires dont vous
disposez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il y as we une diminution des
investissements prévus c'est
probablement les choix qui ont été les
plus douloureux à faire à deux milliards
d'euros
il ya une diminution de la dépense au
sein du ministère de la défense
nationale je voudrais rendre hommage à
jean yves le drian qui remplit sa
mission avec un sens des responsabilités
un sens du devoir absolument remarquable
et qui parvient à maîtriser cette
dépense sans que pour autant et
quelconque budget de rupture
interviennent aux troupes seront
rapatriés d'afghanistan et accueillis
dans des conditions tout à fait
correctes et aucun des programmes
d'investissements militaires qui
conditionne la sécurité nationale de
notre pays dans les années à venir aucun
de ces programmes
les sacrifiés c'est un budget de
transition que nous avons pu élaborer et
certainement pas un budget de rupture
pour autant il ya bien une économie de
2,2 milliards d'euros la chose n'est pas
négligeable il y a une économie sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement de 2 8
milliards d'euros d'économies sur les
dépenses d'intervention de 2 milliards
d'euros bref il ya une économie
incontestable de 10 milliards d'euros
sur le budget de l'état auxquels se
rajoutent bien sur l'économie que nous
demandons à la protection sociale avec
un un objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance-maladie de 2 7% soit une
économie de 2,4 milliards d'euros bref
l'année
prochaine et toute l'administration
publique confondues il y aura bien une
économie de 12,5 milliards d'euros la
chose ne fut pas si fréquentes qu'elles
puissent être passés sous silence ou
pire ignoré par les uns et par les
autres
fut-ce pour servir les intérêts
politiques partisans que toute
opposition se doit de servir j'ai été
parlementaire de l'opposition
je sais parfaitement ce qu'est cet
exercice contre 1 obligé sans surprise
classique
nous nous livrerons bien sûr les uns et
les autres à cet exercice là c'est la
démocratie quitté le commander chacun le
fera bien évidemment en conscience donc
ces économies sont là qui net des
politiques nouvelles montre bien que le
gouvernement après avoir indiqué sa
volonté de rompre avec les termes d'une
équation budgétaire impossible mais en
oeuvre cette volonté de rupture afin que
la parole de la france retrouve une
force qu'objectivement elle avait en
partie perdu précisément parce que
d'autres pays s'avérait incapable de
tenir des engagements budgétaires et
financiers pris pourtant et auprès de la
commission et auprès de nos principaux
partenaires
j ai indiqué je crois il ya peu et dans
cette enceinte ce qu'il en était des
économies attendues de la protection
sociale je dis un mot bien sûr et
collectivités locales ne pas le faire
dans cette enceinte serait plus qu'un
oubli ferait une faute vous le savez les
dotations sous plafond bénéficieront si
je peux me permettre cette expression de
la norme zéro valeur mais il a été
décidé que le fonds de compensation à la
tva serait sorti de ce champ zéro valeur
car il ne faut pas contraindre
excessivement les collectivités dès lors
qu'elles souhaitent investir
l'investissement
c'est probablement une bonne dette dès
lors qu en partie ceux ci sont financées
par l'emprunt l'investissement peut
servir sert aux générations futures et
leur demander d'y contribuer par le
remboursement de cette dette n'est pas
en soi un scandale si cela peut l'être
dès lors qu'il s'agirait de rembourser
des dépenses de fonctionnement dont nous
sortons le fctva de cette norme zéro
valeur et vous savez puisque ce texte a
été examiné par votre assemblée dans le
cadre du budget triennal il sera demandé
un effort aux collectivités locales via
une diminution de la dotation sous
plafond de 750 me
on d'euros en 2014 et à nouveau 750
millions d'euros
l'année suivante il nous semble que cet
effort d'un milliard et demi sur trois
ans 2% si l'on prend la totalité des
dotations d'état il nous semble que cet
effort est supportable
il est vrai que l'état par lui même et à
lui seul ne peut assumer le retour à
l'équilibré de nos finances unique
toutes les administrations publiques
devront y concourir
naturellement en proportion de leur
disponibilité bien sûr en fonction du
rôle essentiel que les unes et les
autres peuvent jouer et si l'état doit
prendre si vous me passez l'expression
la part du lion dans cet effort les
autres administrations publiques ne
peuvent être exonérés de cet effort-là
aux deux grands camps et parlementaires
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition
et hier dans la majorité s'exprimer sur
ce sujet il ya de cela quelques mois ou
quelques années les mêmes reconnaissait
que cet effort-là devait être partagé je
n'imagine pas qu'ils puissent tenir
aujourd'hui un autre langage
sauf peut-être à donner l'impression de
se dédire ce qui n'est jamais très bon
lorsque l'on souhaite être crédible en
tout cas avec terre-neuve comme ici nous
efforcerons de ne pas courir ce risque
là est supposé que nous donnions cette
impression nous savons pouvoir compter
sur l'extrême vigilance du président de
la commission des finances
pour nous le rappeler est donc le même
président comprendra que dès lors qu'il
nous le rappellerai nous agirions de
même à son égard
voilà donc l'effort qu'il est demandé de
consentir voilà donc à grands traits
j'espère que me le pardonnerai mais la
discussion permettra de rentrer dans le
détail des choses
la présentation de ce budget dont la
caractéristique essentielle
je le maintiens et bien de s'inscrire
dans un ensemble qui doit concourir à
restaurer la santé de nos finances
publiques pour les raisons maintes fois
évoquée dans cette enceinte râpé par
pierre moscovici à l'instant que je
m'étais permis moi même d'indiquer lors
de la présentation des précédents textes
c'est un budget difficile c'est un
budget qui va donc demander des efforts
gens dit quelques mots maintenant oui il
y aura des efforts demandés aux ménages
avec par exemple une tranche marginale à
45% temps maintenant d'ailleurs la
contribution exceptionnelle dite
contribution carrese
du nom du précédent rapporteur général
ump de l'assemblée nationale oui il y
aura une réforme de l'impôt sur la
fortune non pas avec une restitution à
bini sio de ce qu'était cet impôt sur la
fortune
chacun a pu voir ce qu'il en est des
taux et du plafonnement mais avec une
restauration au moins partielle des
recettes abandonné l'année dernière fut
ce qu'est la précédente majorité avait
cru bon alors même que nos finances
publiques se dégrader considérablement
d'abandonner près de 2 milliards d'euros
de recettes au titre de l isf au même
moment où d'ailleurs la même majorité
augmenter la csg pour l'ensemble des
salariés doubler la taxe sur les
mutuelles pour l'ensemble des
mutualistes au même moment où d'ailleurs
des plans complémentaires fillon un
fillon 2 commencé à être élaboré je
voudrais rappeler que la précédente
majorité n'a pas été en arrière de la
main si vous me permettez cette
expression habituel en équitation
n'avait pas été en arrière de la main
lorsqu'il s'était agi de solliciter les
français via des impôts et des taxes
nouvelles
fillon s'était quand même 11 milliards
d'euros de prélèvements nouveaux et pas
un centime d'économie fillon 2 c'était 8
milliard d'euros de prélèvements
supplémentaires et pas un centime
d'euros d'économies hélas hélas monsieur
le président la commission des finances
ces sommes sont évidemment nécessaires
servir la raison pour lesquelles vous
les aviez décidé vous qui aviez la
religion de la baisse des impôts pendant
des années des années si vous vous être
résolu en toute fin de période de ces
dix années où on suit majoritaire
d'augmenter les impôts c'est bien parce
que vous n'aviez pas d'autre moyen que
de les augmenter
après les avoir baissés peut-être de
manière inconsidérée toutes ces années
précédentes et donc l'effort fut violent
fut rude notamment sur le plan politique
pour ceux qui imitent années durant et
d'affilée avait baissé ses ressources et
qu'ils ont dû ensuite les augmenter
brutalement oui il a fallu augmenter ses
ressources parce que oui il a fallu
respecter la parole de la france et en
finir avec un endettement sans fin un
endettement conséquent un engouement
grandissant qui finissaient par
compromettre toute action publique à
l'intérieur de nos frontières et toute
parole donnée à l'extérieur de celle-ci
donc nous assumons ce que vous avez fait
et
espérons que vous assumerez autant que
nous le faisons ce que nous nous
apprêtons à proposer au sénat d'ici les
quelques heures à venir
alors oui un effort est donc demandé
j'ai l'indiqué ce qu'ils ont été pour
les ménages et bien sûr il y aura cette
réforme de l'impôt sur le revenu qui
reviendra en réalité aligner les revenus
du capital au même barème à l'impôt sur
le revenu que les revenus du travail
avec quelques modalités particulières à
l'occasion le gouvernement les assumera
parfaitement au nom de la compétitivité
au nom de la nécessité de relancer
l'économie au nom de l'impérieuse
obligation de ne pas décourager
l'investissement mais dans l'ensemble
est très majoritairement les revenus du
capital vont donc être soumis au même
barème à l'impôt sur le revenu que les
revenus du travail c'est une réforme
considérable dans d'ailleurs si on veut
bien en avoir un peu le souvenir le
précédent président de la république
avait jeté les bases et je m'étonne donc
ceux qui se réclamaient de ce précédent
président la république condamne avec
autant de force que nous apprêtons à
faire lors même que celui qui soutenait
à l'époque dans son action puis dans sa
cape campagne électorale avait lui même
indiqué qu'il lui paraissait peut-être
nécessaire de modifier notre fiscalité
dans ce sens là ce il est vrai qu'il
avait beaucoup parler en ce sens là mais
que ceux qui l'avaient suggéré ou
demander de faire à son gouvernement
était allé en sens inverse chacun ses
contradictions vous nous permettrait de
les relever
à l'occasion vu ce que nous avons lu
notre don vous n'épargnez aucune
citation ni aucune démonstration mais là
encore c'est le débat démocratique qui
s'imposent et chacun peut en accepter
les termes efforts également auprès des
entreprises avec la même philosophie
ce sont les entreprises qui le peuvent
que nous sollicitons et caen indique les
entreprises qui le peuple je veux dire
celle qui nonobstant cet effort
continuerons à investir
il en est ainsi par exemple de la
réduction de l'avantagé de ce qu'on
appelle la niche copé
probablement mal nommé puisque
courageusement le président de
commission des finances du sénat a
toujours indiqué que cette niche devrait
s'appeler la niche marini et non la
niche copé
peut-être monsieur président de la
commission des finances devront
consentir à ce que celui qui finit par
donner son nom à cette niche a
finalement plus connu et d'une notoriété
supérieure à vous encore que et
notamment l'accueil terre exemples
démontrent pas forcément pour des
raisons qui
pour lui-même était évidemment
souhaitable mais je suis sûr que je suis
sûr qu'au delà de l'indignation que vous
manifestez et dont je devine qu'elle est
en partie factice parce que j'ai appris
à vous connaître monsieur le président
la commission des finances
vous saurez trouver les arguments
auxquels je répondrai naturellement il
demeure ce que j'ai dit est vrai cette
niche devrait s'appeler alice marini
soudan formaliserait pas il se trouve
qu'elle s'appelle la niche copé ainsi
baptisés ainsi elle restera et donc la
niche copé sera en partie réformer avec
une économie pour les finances publiques
tout à fait conséquente de l'ordre de
deux milliards d'euros au moins pour les
finances publiques
nous pouvons nous en réjouir également
un effort sera demandé à ces entreprises
qui ont pris l'habitude de reporter en
avant des déficits constitués dans les
années précédentes
jusqu alors ils pouvaient reporter
jusqu'à 60 % cela sera désormais 50%
bien sûr avec une franchise pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises car il
ne s'agit pas de gêner ces entreprises
là voilà donc mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
les principales mesures à la fois de
recettes et d'économies qui permet au
gouvernement de présenter ce budget
devant la haute assemblée
avec la très sincère conviction que ce
budget est indispensable il faut rompre
avec l'endettement avait 4 et sincère
conviction aussi que ce budget est juste
car l'effort demandé les et aux ménages
et aux entreprises qui le peuvent avec
la très sincère conviction qu une année
difficile s'annonce pour notre pays car
c'est jamais ça n'est jamais de gaieté
de coeur qu'un gouvernement s'apprête à
demander des efforts aux pays demander
au parlement de voter ces efforts que le
pays devra assumer
c'est un économiste d'avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
s'appeler bettelheim qui indiquait il
faut se souvenir de ce qui pouvait dire
que quand l'on cesse de compter c'est la
peine des gens que l'on oublie alors oui
nous comptons alors oui avec pierre
moscovici nous continuerons à compter
parce que nous ne voulons pas oublier la
peine des gens que nous allons
solliciter pour redresser le pays
cette peine des gens qui va permettre le
redressement du pays pour que la france
retrouve la prospérité retrouve sa
compétitivité retrouve une force en
europe et dans le concert des nations
retrouve une place qu'elle avait
probablement en partie perdue
car notre économie aller mal tant il est
vrai et nous en sommes tous convaincus
que la puissance d'un pays ne se mesure
pas seulement au nombre de sous-marins
nucléaires lanceurs d'engins ou un siège
de représentant permanent au conseil de
sécurité des nations-unies la force de
pays d'un pays se mesure aussi à son
économie et à la force de son industrie
beaucoup d'efforts sont à faire à cet
égard le gouvernement les demandera au
parlement pour que le pays les
constantes
ce budget s'inscrit dans cet ensemble
dont je veux redire qu'il est grave mais
que le gouvernement le tient pour
absolument nécessaire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre l la parole
est à présent à monsieur françois marc
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances
c'est le président messieurs les
ministres que le brillant de la
commission des finances avait mes chers
collègues nous entamons aujourd'hui au
sénat la discussion d'un projet de loi
de finances dont nous savons qu'ils
devaient ils devraient être complétés
bientôt par des dispositions qui
inscriront dans notre droit
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et l'emploi annoncé par le premier
ministre le 6 novembre dernier
alors je m'empresse de préciser que
cette situation n'a rien à voir avec ce
que nous avons vécu à l'automne 2009
lorsque nous avons débattu d'une loi de
finances fantômes dont il était acquis
que l' équilibre serait bouleversé dès
le mois de janvier par le collectif
budgétaire sur les fameuses
investissements d'avenir
cette situation n'a rien de comparable
non plus avec celle de l'année dernière
lorsque rappelez-vous le plan fillon a
entraîné le vote de dispositions loi de
finances au sénat en collectif à
l'assemblée nationale de sorte que les
composantes de l' équilibre budgétaire
de 2012
résultat largement d'une loi de finances
rectificative ici la réforme qui est
annoncée sera sans effet significatif
sur le sol de 2013
s'il est nécessaire de la voter si vite
on sait que c'est pour que les
entreprises puissent en bénéficier le
plus rapidement possible alors si je
commence mon propos en évoquant ce texte
à venir
c'est parce que son annonce apporte un
éclairage utile sur le projet de loi de
finances dont nous débattons
depuis le débat d'orientation des
finances publiques du mois de juillet le
gouvernement et la majorité a insisté
sur la nécessité de mettre en oeuvre des
mesures favorables à la compétitivité de
notre économie
certains imaginent un qu'il s'agissait
d'un discours d'une posture
eh bien ils savent désormais qu'il
s'agit d'une volonté politique
j'invite donc ceux qui doutent de la
détermination du goût
demant sur tel ou tel point par exemple
en matière de réduction des dépenses
publiques
à méditer cet exemple sur ce point comme
sur les autres les engagements pris
seront tenus et nous ne pourrons que
donner acte aux gouvernements de sa
grande détermination pour ma part
j'aurais évidemment souhaité que le
gouvernement trouve au sénat une large
majorité pour le soutenir dans la
redoutable tâche qui est la sienne qui
consiste à réduire de 30 milliards
d'euros en une seule année le déficit
des administrations publiques afin de
permettre à notre pays de respecter
l'objectif qui a été fixé par le conseil
dans le cadre de la procédure de déficit
excessif dont nous faisons l'objet
depuis 2009
cet objectif c'est bien sûr le retour du
déficit sous le seuil des 3% de pib
outre la france on le sait six autres
états européens se doivent d'atteindre
cet objectif en 2013 mais je me dois de
constater que nous entamons aujourd'hui
notre discussion dans une assemblée qui
a refusé de valider la trajectoire des
finances publiques dans laquelle ce
projet de loi de finance s'inscrit en
rejetant le 31 octobre dernier le projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques je n'oublie pas non plus que
notre assemblée a rejeté la semaine
dernière l'autre lois financières
annuelles le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
autant en commission des finances
l'ensemble de la première partie a reçu
un vote favorable
ce matin nous avons confirmé ou
clarifier nos positions sur les crédits
les différentes missions et sur les
articles qui leur sont rattachés verrons
mercredi soir si nous trouvons une
majorité pour passer à la deuxième
partie et plus largement c'est
l'objectif de redressement des finances
publiques de la france contenu dans ce
budget 2013 est ou non partagé par une
majorité d'entre nous
ce que je m'autorise à croire le sénat
sera-t-il au rendez-vous historique
qu'on se conduisant depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale à un tel effort
d'assainissement des finances publiques
la question nous
oser et c'est dans cette perspective que
nous allons nous mobiliser tout au long
de ce débat
pour ma part j'ai un vide
en tout état de cause à ce que le
gouvernement ne dévie en rien du cap
qu'il s'est fixé
car la crise de la zone euro n'est pas
fini les investisseurs le perçoivent
toujours pas notre zone monétaire comme
un ensemble cohérent si les choses
n'évoluent pas plus mal c'est parce que
les européens ont réussi à faire passer
l'idée qu'ils sont sinon solidaire du
mois unis la banque centrale européenne
a fait beaucoup à cet égard les états
européens ont pris leur part et sont
parvenus à lancer le mécanisme européen
de stabilité
on parle beaucoup moins ces temps ci
dans la presse de notre pare feu contre
les attaques spéculatives sur nos dettes
souveraines il n'empêche que l'enjeu
demeure cruciale et que la consolidation
de la zone euro reste notre première
priorité
y compris sur le plan budgétaire dans ce
projet de loi de finances nous dépensons
6,5 milliards d'euros pour doter le
mécanisme européen solidarité en capital
si la plus grosse dépense nouvelle de ce
budget nous ne lésinons pas avec la
stabilité de la zone euro car toutes nos
finances publiques en dépendent
le lien entre secteur bancaire et dette
souveraine peut encore produire des
effets redoutables et c'est pour cela
que l'union bancaire doit vite voir le
jour quand l'europe n'avance plus elle
recule et faut donc se réjouir que la
france soit aux avant-postes du camp du
progrès et du mouvement dans ce contexte
le gouvernement doit être présent sur
trois fronts à la fois sans qu'il soit
possible de les hiérarchiser au risque
de fragiliser ensemble premier front la
discipline budgétaire qu'on le veuille
ou non la capacité à respecter sa
trajectoire de finances publiques est un
élément désormais essentiel de la
crédibilité des états deuxième front la
compétitivité et la recherche de la
croissance de l'économie si on considère
que la crise de la zone euro
s'explique mieux par les déséquilibres
des balances des paiements que par les
finances publiques
alors il nous faut remédier à notre
déficit du commerce extérieur et
troisième front enfin la justice sociale
une nouvelle majorité a été élu au
printemps elle doit répondre aux
attentes qui se sont exprimées
elle doit le faire parce que les efforts
qui seront demandés seront acceptés
s'ils sont perçus comme justement
répartis elle doit le faire parce que le
chômage et la crise menace la cohésion
de notre société
elle doit le faire parce que les
inégalités sociales se creusent dans
notre pays et qu'il ne faut pas s'y
résoudre
de mon point de vue ce projet de loi
finances répond aux attentes sur les
trois points
du point de vue de la discipline
budgétaire je rappelle juste que le
déficit budgétaire de l'état serait
ramené de plus de 83 milliards d'euros à
61 milliards d'euros l'une des plus
forte baisse jamais enregistrée
le déficit primaire se réduisant de 60%
pour retrouver un niveau d'avant la
crise pour tenir le déficit de la
méthode est connue elle vise en
particulier à interdire que les dépenses
de l'état ne progressent plus vite que
l'inflation
elle vise à stabiliser en valeur des
dépenses autres que la charge de la
dette et les pensions cela implique de
réaliser une dizaine de milliards
d'euros d'économies en mettant à
contribution pour ce qui est du
fonctionnement et des interventions
l'ensemble des ministères sur la
implique de stabiliser les effectifs et
la masse salariale alors cet effort sur
les dépenses est conçu dans la durée car
le fonctionnement des services publics
ne peut s'accommoder de coups
d'accordéon qui conduirait à réduire
massivement les crédits une année pour
en ré attribuées l'année suivante
mais j'entends déjà la critique sur ce
qui serait le point faible où l'un des
deux principaux points faibles de ce
projet de loi de finances à savoir la
concentration
sur l'année 2013 de l'effort en recettes
pour ce qui concerne le budget de l'état
on ajoute une quinzaine de milliards
d'euros de hausse d'impôts aux 4
milliards issus des effets en 2013 des
mesures votées par la majorité
précédente et aux 3 milliards issus des
effets 2013 des mesures du collectif
budgétaire
et bien mes chers collègues de mon point
de vue ce choix est le meilleur possible
comme je l'avais expliqué au moment du
collectif budgétaire à court terme
les hausses d'impôts sont moins
récessive que les baisses de dépenses et
les travaux théoriques récent du fonds
monétaire international ne font que
confirmer cette analyse
de mon point de vue l'affichage de
mesures de recettes lisible et bien
calibrés ne peut que crédibiliser notre
détermination à respecter l'objectif de
déficit de 3% du pib en 2013
l'autre faiblesse à l'égard du projet de
loi de finances c'est l'hypothèse de
croissance du pib dont dépend notamment
l'évolution spontanée des recettes
on peut toujours se livrer à des
exercices de simulation pour évaluer les
effets sur le sol d'une prévision de
croissance différente de celle retenue
par le gouvernement
c'est tout à fait légitime et cela
permet de se préparer à toutes les
éventualités
en revanche pour contester une hypothèse
de croissance il faut être autrement
armés
certes les gouvernements toujours un
billet optimistes dans leurs prévisions
je constate simplement mes chers
collègues que l'écart constaté cette
année avec le consensus des économistes
n'est pas plus grand que d'habitude je
rappelle aussi que à l'initiative du
sénat la nouvelle loi organique sur les
finances publiques oblige le futur au
conseil des finances publiques à se
référer au consensus pour apprécier les
hypothèses retenues dans les lois de
finances
j'en tire comme conclusion qu'il est
inutile de chercher de mauvaises
querelles c'est à d et que dès le 1er
mars la donne aura changé avec la
création du haut conseil des finances
publiques
j'en viens maintenant à la compétitivité
à la recherche de la croissance
ce sujet nous occupera dans les semaines
qui viennent avec la mise en place du
crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi
quoi que l'on pense de la décision et
des motivations de l'agencé moody's
ces derniers jours qui l'ont conduite à
dégrader d'un cran la note de la france
il nous faut en tirer la conclusion que
les réformes structurelles ne peuvent
attendre et qu'il faut les mettre en
oeuvre le plus vite possible
mais cette préoccupation est déjà
présente dans l'action google du
gouvernement vous l'aurez noté
l'éducation figure parmi les premières
priorités budgétaires tout de même des
emplois d'avenir ont été créés on va
étendre le crédit d'impôt recherche à
l'innovation
on va proroger tel quel le régime des
fonds communs de placement dans
l'innovation et les fonds
d'investissement de proximité
j'en viens pour finir à la justice
sociale
on se souviendra de ce projet de loi de
finances comme de celui du retour à la
progressivité de l'impôt sur le revenu
le ministre nous l'a dit on crée une
nouvelle tranche de 45 % dans le barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu on crée même
pour deux ans une tranche à 75% pour les
plus hauts revenus on atténue voir on
annule grâce à la décote les effets du
gel du barème pour les premières
tranches
on baisse le plafond du quotient
familial
on abaisse de manière importante le
plafond global des niches fiscales même
si c'est vrai on réduit un peu son
assiette
on se souviendra aussi de ce projet de
loi de finances comme celui qui a permis
de taxer
les revenus de l'épargné au même barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est une
réforme juste car la plupart des
contribuables perdent aujourd'hui avec
le régime du prélèvement libératoire
tandis qu'un petit nombre
on sait lesquels y gagne massivement
c'est une réforme qui devra n'en pas
douter être ajustés dans les années qui
viennent
compte tenu de son ampleur c'est une
réforme qui va rouvrir le débat sur la
qualification de certains revenus
et je pense notamment aux carrières
interest
si les états unis d'amérique évolué vers
une taxation de ses revenus
alignée sur celle des revenus du travail
pourrons-nous ne pas aller un jour dans
le même sens
la réponse est naturellement non et nous
devons réfléchir à une progression dans
cette direction évidemment l'impôt sur
le revenu plus groupes progressifs
s'accompagne d'un impôt sur la fortune à
nouveau capable de jouer son rôle de
taxation de la faculté contributive
qu'apporte la détention patrimoine tout
en respectant les contraintes
constitutionnelles
nous allons aussi débattre d'un projet
de loi de finances riche en mesures en
faveur du logement
tout d'abord des mesures qui doivent
relancer l'offre de foncier dans les
zones où elles manquent le plus avec une
réforme du régime des plus values
immobilières mélangeant l'incitation
pour les cessions d'immeubles bâtis et
la sanction de la rétention pour les
terrains à bâtir dont l'abattement pour
durée de détention sur à supprimer dans
le même but le projet de loi de finances
propose d'étendre et de renforcer la
taxe sur les logements vacants et rend
systématique dans les mêmes zones
tendues la majoration de la valeur
locative cadastrale des terrains
constructibles
vous le voyez bien tout est fait pour
remettre des biens et les terrains sur
le marché il ya aussi plusieurs mesures
qui sont destinés à favoriser la
construction et le logement
un nouveau dispositif des aides à
l'investissement locatif
duflot comme on l'appelle plus sociale
et recentré géographiquement qui prendra
la suite du sellier en évitant de
reproduire ses défauts et la
prolongation jusqu'en 2016 des actuels
régime des aides à l'investissement dans
le meublé non professionnel pour le
logement étudiant les établissements
pour personnes âgées et les résidences
de tourisme classées
reste la question de l'accession à la
propriété
il nous est proposé d'accorder la
garantie de l'état à une banque le
crédit immobilier de france qui ne
parvient plus à se financer sur les
marchés dont une part significative de
l'activité consiste à accorder des prêts
aux ménages modestes et dont les
résultats servent à financer les
missions sociales de ses actionnaires
laisse à sicap qui vise essentiellement
on le sait en la solvabilisation des
ménages pour leur permettre de financer
les travaux de rénovation de leur
logement
dell annonce de l'intention du
gouvernement d'accorder cette garantie
en début de mois de septembre
notre commission des finances s'est
mobilisée sur ce sujet nous avons
organisé une table ronde ouverte à tous
les sénateurs le 3 octobre
depuis cette table ronde le dossier a
évolué les députés ont organisé des
auditions de leur côté et la commission
des finances a mis en place un groupe de
travail et je rendrai compte de nos
travaux à la commission des finances le
4 décembre prochain
lorsque nous nous réunirons pour
examiner en commission ce fameux article
66 en attendant en attendant nous avons
adopté en commission un amendement à
l'article 30 qui a pour objet sur ce
sujet du seuil f d'inviter le
gouvernement à envisager toutes les
conséquences directes et indirectes de
ce qui est en train de se passer et qui
nous préoccupe fortement dans ce plf
nous allons aussi examiner des articles
qui rétablissent l'équité fiscale entre
les petites moyennes et grandes
entreprises c'est un sujet dont nous
avons souvent débattu en particulier
l'un
dernière dans le projet de loi de
finances et nous avions attiré
l'attention sur la nécessité de nous
occuper beaucoup plus activement des pme
et de leur situation fiscale
le plafonnement de la déductibilité des
intérêts d'emprunt réduira l'écart de
taux effectif d'impôt sur les sociétés
entre les petites et les grandes
entreprises et c'est là une réponse à
cette préoccupation que nous exprimions
ici au sénat depuis déjà de nombreuses
années
vous comprendrez messieurs les ministres
que le sénat ne serait plus le sénat
s'ils ne souhaitaient pas que la
préoccupation de justice ne s'étende pas
aux collectivités locales
les collectivités doivent bien entendu
participer à l'effort collectif de
redressement des cons ça on est tous
d'accord pour l'admettre
parce qu'elle représente on le sait à
des postes de dépenses les plus
importants de l'état soit presque 20 %
des dépenses hors fiscalité transférer
et parce que le respect des objectifs de
progression des dépenses publiques
figurant dans la programmation
pluriannuelle dépend aussi de la manière
dont elles contiennent leurs dépenses
mais elle doit faire jouer la solidarité
entre elles et accepter le renforcement
des dispositifs de péréquation
elles doivent évidemment être associés à
la définition des nouvelles règles qui
leur seront appliquées et mieux être
associée au contrôle des normes mais les
meilleures règles du jeu sont
inopérantes si les dés sont pipés
or si on ne réforme pas les valeurs
locatives sur lesquelles sont assis les
impôts locaux
rien ne garantit que l'on prélèvera les
plus riches et que les plus pauvres
seront les mieux dotés rien ne garantit
que les efforts seront demandés à ceux
qui peuvent le plus contribué au sein
des collectivités et entre elles vous
avez voté au mois de juillet mon
amendement qui proposait de généraliser
la révision des valeurs locatives
professionnels et le gouvernement avait
soutenu cette initiative
j'espère que dans le collectif
budgétaire
que nous examinons dans les jours à
venir
il en sera de même pour l'amendement que
je vous présenterai afin de proposer une
expérimentation de la révision des
valeurs locatives des locaux
d'habitation en vue de leur extension à
l'ensemble du champ des valeurs
locatives
le gouvernement a accepté au mois de
juillet mon amendement qui proposait de
généraliser l'expérience de révision des
valeurs locatives professionnels
j'espère que dans le collectif
il acceptera encore cet amendement qui
proposera une expérimentation de la
valeur sur les valeurs locatives des
locaux d'habitation
voilà mes chers collègues les éléments
relatifs à ce contenu des lois de
finances et à l'esprit dans lequel cette
loi aujourd'hui s'inscrit je rappelle
bien entendu le sénat soutenir
activement ce projet de loi de finances
mais je ne peux pas me souvenir que
l'année dernière
la majorité sénatoriale nouvellement
élus avaient convaincu le dernier budget
du quinquennat précédent mais qu'elle
avait aussi mis en avant sa vision de la
politique des finances publiques
rappelez vous il ya un an de cela à la
commission des finances nous avions
élaboré une trajectoire de retour à
l'équilibré en 2010 est fondé sur 50
milliards d'euros d'économies de
dépenser 50 milliards d'euros de
recettes supplémentaires 50 50 c'est
bien l'esprit dans lequel le
gouvernement nous présente aujourd'hui
sa trajectoire budgétaire pour les
années qui viennent et nous ne pouvons
donc que nous satisfaire de cette
réponse qui est apporté à notre
préconisations en séance rappelez-vous
nous avions remis en cause les mesures
phares de la législature précédente tout
en jetant les bases d'une réforme
fiscale qui serait selon nous fonder sur
un impôt sur le revenu plus progressif
c'est quelque chose qui est acté une
taxation au barème des revenus du
patrimoine
disposition qui est actée dans ce projet
de loi un impôt sur la fortune renforcer
disposition qui a été actée dans ce
projet de loi une déductibilité des
charges financières plafonné etc etc
très clairement mes chers collègues
cet exercice de préparation budgétaire
qui a été fait au sénat l'an passé à
trouver de très nombreuses réponses dans
le projet de loi de finances qui est
nous est soumis je fais ce rappel pour
vous dire que je me retrouve
parfaitement le projet de loi de
finances qui nous est soumis et dont je
souhaite qu'ils puissent être votées par
le plus grand nombre d'entre nous je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à philippe marini président
de la commission des finances
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
d'habitude la loi de finances initiale
le budget c'est le texte fondateur de la
politique économique plus exactement
c'est le symbole est l' axe fort
l'expression de la volonté d'un
gouvernement de la majorité qui le
soutient pour aborder l'exercice qui
vient c'est ce que devrait être en
théorie une loi de finances un budget de
l'exercice qui vient alors au moment où
nous entamons l'examen de ce texte
qu'en est il je ne peux pour ma part que
noter le décalage de plus en plus grand
de ce texte tel qu'il a été élaboré cet
été tel qu'il a été arrêté par le
conseil des ministres en septembre
dernier par rapport à la réalité
économique financière sociale
internationale du temps présent
bien sûr le cadre macroéconomique est en
cause
les hypothèses de croissance que
monsieur ministre de l'économie a
qualifié au demeurant comme la longue
série de ses prédécesseurs qu'il a
qualifiées de volontaristes 0 8% 2 %
pour les années suivantes
lorsque nous lisons les appréciations
des instituts de conjoncture des
économistes lorsque nous écoutons
le fonds monétaire international la
commission européenne tous les experts
oui ces estimations du gouvernement se
situe sur la branche haute voire au delà
de la branche haute de la fourchette et
nous savons bien que tout excès de
prévisions de croissance implique si la
réalité n'est pas au rendez vous une
révision douloureuse en cours d'année
c'est purement mécanique
si l'appréciation des recettes des
recettes fiscales en particulier des
impôts sur les entreprises
si cette appréciation est excessive et
déraisonnable
si les chiffres sont revues en baisse en
cours d'année
il faudra réaliser des économies de
dépenses supplémentaires allant bien au
delà des 10 milliards d'inflexion de la
trajectoire dont vous nous avez plaît en
second lieu et surtout cette loi de
finances initiale me paraît être le
dernier acte de ce qu'était votre
politique économique l'été dernier c'est
à dire le dernier acte de l'ancienne
politique avant le tournant ou du moins
avant l' inflexion qui a été préparé il
faut le dire
habilement par le rapport de louis
gallois et en troisième lieu
troisième facteur de décalage de la loi
de finances par rapport à la réalité
c'est l'information hélas trop banalisé
de la semaine dernière sur la perte par
notre pays du triple à
s'agissant d'une seconde agence de
notation prenant cette position
alors j'ai bien entendu les les
commentaires qui ont été faits et je
dois dire monsieur ministre de
l'économie que de même que certains
propos tenus tout à l'heure par le
ministre du budget dont je ne manque
jamais une occasion de souligner
l'habileté le professionnalisme le sens
parlementaire et bien ce que j'ai
déplorés dans les propos qui ont été
tenus par l'exécutif c'est le caractère
polémique partisans des remarques qui
ont été faites hors caisse qui est en
cause
qu'est ce qui est en cause ce n'est pas
la responsabilité des uns ou la
responsabilité des autres ce ne sont pas
les mérites respectifs de valérie
pécresse ou de jérôme cahuzac
ceci n'a strictement aucun intérêt
ce qui est en cause mes chers collègues
payer mes côtés jusqu'au bout c'est le
crédit de la france c'est la confiance
que l'on peut avoir en nous ce qui est
en cause c'est notre position de premier
émetteur en euros en 2013
160 milliards d'euros vont devoir être
recherchée sur ces marchés financiers
que l'on ose plus aujourd'hui considérés
comme des ennemis
et ce qui est en cause c'est de savoir
comment nous parviendrons à ses 3 % qui
sont l'alpha et l'oméga de nos
engagements
ce qui est en cause c'est la crédibilité
du chemin car l'objectif de 3%
de ce côté-ci bien entendu vous le savez
nous y adhérons totalement et au
demeurant si nous n'avions pas à porter
nos voix à la loi organique qui est
directement issu du nouveau traité
européen le tsc g vous savez fort bien
messieurs les mini
que ce texte n'aurait pas été voté par
le sénat
les 3% nous y adhérons totalement
c'est notre engagement nous le
partageons
il provient des responsabilités qui ont
été prises courageusement par la
précédente majorité en particulier par
le gouvernement dirigé par françois
fillon et et c'est 3%
c'est 3% pour y parvenir mais chers
collègues
pour y parvenir il va falloir réaliser
un très sérieux efforts et bien
davantage il va falloir être très
crédible et de ce point de vue
permettez-moi de m'étonner et permettez
moi d'exprimer toutes mes craintes et de
le faire un peu solennellement à l'égard
de ce que l'on nous dit ces jours ci on
nous dit que dans le prochain texte
financier le projet de loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année
nous aurions non pas comme on le fait
d'habitude a examiné le fourre tout des
dispositions indispensables ou opportune
nous n'aurions pas seulement à ajuster
les comptes de l'année en cours mais
nous aurions a décidé du premier acte de
la nouvelle politique économique
la loi de finances dernier rack de
l'ancienne politique de la politique
transitoire est de mon point de vue
quelque peu revancharde de l'été dernier
et la loi de finances rectificative qui
va venir devant nous le premier acte de
la nouvelle politique donc de la
politique d'après le tournant or dans la
contrainte des 3% pour inspirer
confiance à nos investisseurs est ce
qu'il ne serait pas logique messieurs
les ministres de voter à la fois les
dépenses et les ressources
est ce qu'ils les responsables
d'envisager fût ce un seul instant de
faire voter par le parlement le crédit
d'impôt c'est à dire ce qui est agréable
nos entreprises et de renvoyer un autre
texte la hausse de la tva et de renvoyer
un autre texte les économies de dépenses
supplémentaires
est ce que ce serait responsable
et est ce que ce serait de nature à
inspirer confiance à celles et ceux qui
nous regardent qui nous observent qui
nous scrutent qui détermine qui
détermine le prix de nos emprunts est ce
que l'on a oublié qu'au cours de cette
année 2012
une bonne surprise est enregistrée et
dont nous aurons à connaître dans cette
loi de finances rectificative de fin
d'année une économie de 2,4 milliards
d'euros sur les intérêts de la dette et
sans cela nous n'arrivions manifestement
pas à tenir les objectifs qui avaient
été fixés au début de l'année 2012 dans
une loi de finances initiale qui était
parfaitement responsable qui a été
modifiée au demeurant au cours de
l'année comme il était logique et normal
de le faire
messieurs les ministres je me permets de
vous poser cette question est-il
vraiment raisonnable est il responsable
d' envisager de demander au parlement
d'examiner en deux temps ce dispositif
de compétitivité est il raisonnable est
il responsable de commencer par créer
des engagements pour demain pour
après-demain des engagements de dépenses
avec pour contrepartie une amélioration
réputé immédiate de la situation
financière des entreprises
vous nous direz c'est un crédit d'impôt
il n'y a pas de dépense budgétaire en
2013 certes mais si les entreprises
constatent une créance et bien que
quelqu'un d'autre en face constate une
dette
cela veut bien dire que l'état prend un
engagement qu'il devra honorer qui
pèsera sur ses finances publiques au
cours des années à venir et notamment de
est ce qu'il ne serait pas logique
raisonnable et responsable de dire voilà
le volet pour contribuer à la
compétitivité et qui suppose de
restaurer les bilans des entreprises et
qui suppose de leur rendre d'ailleurs
une partie peut être pas tout à fait au
même entreprise certes une partie des
prélèvements supplémentaires qui sont
dans la loi de finances initiale pour
l'année 2013
mais est ce que est ce que vraiment vous
envisagez de faire cela c'est à dire de
nous faire voter
l'engagement financier de l'état
l'aspect agréable du plan de
compétitivité sans faire voter dans le
même mouvement et l'augmentation de la
tva qu'il va falloir que vous assumiez
nous ça nous pose pas de problème mais
c'est plutôt de ce côté ci qu'il va
falloir que vous en débatte y est n'est
ce pas puisque vous avez commencé la
législature en annulant le peu que nous
avions fait bien tard en matière de
restauration de la compétitivité des
entreprises par un transfert qui n'était
qu'une première étape des charges
sociales vers l'impôt de consommation
permettant de taxer davantage les
importations et exerçant de ce fait un
effet qui aurait pu au fil du temps s'il
avait été amplifiée être significatif
et puis s'agissant des économies vous
nous avez bien dit et quelle entendu
nous prenons bonne note nous engrangeons
tout ce qui va dans le sens vertueux
selon nous mais vous nous avez bien dit
que la nouvelle politique la politique
d'après le tournant elle allait
nécessiter des économies supplémentaires
vous avez cité des chiffres mais
messieurs les ministres ces chiffres il
faut les documenter il faut dire où il
faut dire quand il faut dire avec
quelles conséquences
j'ai même lu tout un commentaire où j'ai
cru retrouver l'exposé des motifs de la
défunte revue générale des politiques
publiques
mais peut-être d'ailleurs s'agit-il des
mêmes hauts fonctionnaires qui ont écrit
les mêmes choses peut-être en tout cas
j'ai observé et non sans un certain
plaisir une continuité complète
s'agissant de la nécessité pour faire
des économies de s'interroger sur les
fonctions et sur l'adéquation des moyens
aux fonctions et aux objectifs que l'on
veut atteindre
donc messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nous allons certes entamé
cette loi de finances pour 2013
je ne vais pas commenter de manière
aussi précise que je serai amené à le
faire dans le cours du débat mais j'ai
voulu souligner d'entrée de jeu le
décalage de ce texte par rapport à la
réalité et l'importance des
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres car
quelle que soit bien sûr nos nos
attaches politiques nos histoires
politiques respectives nos territoires
il y à un seul enjeu que nous devrions
avoir en tête c'est notre pays sa
réforme c'est la france sa crédibilité
et la confiance que ses concitoyens
peuvent avoir dans l'avenir
merci mes chers collègues de votre
attention
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des finances
mes chers collègues messieurs les
ministres devaient donc suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 15 heures
pour les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
la séance est suspendue nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance nous
reviendrons plus en détail dans nos
différentes tranches d'information de
19h et de 22h sur les enjeux de l'examen
du projet de loi de finance par les
sénateurs prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire cet après midi
à 15 heures avec elles les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement très bonne
journée à tous